foreign
[Applause]
state of the nation address President
Putin returned to a well-worn theme the
villainy of the West and his supposed
inability to do anything other than
invade Ukraine
is
foreign
seats some in the audience not quite as
alert as others
as the front line Fight Continues to
extract its terrible toll the president
claimed ukrainians were prepared by the
West for
slaughtered material
one piece of news saved right for the
end that Russia would halt its
obligations under the new start treaty
the last agreement still nominally in
place to stop the proliferation of
nuclear warheads
The Ripping up of the world's Arms
Control architecture has been a two
decades-long process but this is the
final nail in the coffin even if Russia
says it's just suspending participation
in the treaty rather than withdrawing
altogether if the world's nuclear Powers
at assault talking arms control again
there needs to be a lot more trust than
there is now because it's a war evgeny
pop-off was there he's a member of
Parliament and a well-known journalist
for State TV not a man horse stray from
the party line we are a peaceful country
and but we can use Force to defend our
motherland
and this message seems to resonate
certainly with those we met afterwards
[Music]
if people wanted a vision for how this
war ends they did not get one just a
speech infused with bitterness and
paranoia from the man who could end it
in a heartbeat
Sky News
[Applause]